hello bonjour bonjour je cherche le
studio illuminations madoff n'est pas
ici que vous sortez première porte sur
votre droite et c'est au quatrième étage
d'accord merci à moi au revoir au revoir
[Musique]
bonjour c'est gad elmaleh pour moi moche
et méchant
gad elmaleh
je vois gamme blue pour moi moche et
méchant loup j'ai eu un petit goût et
voilà merci beaucoup
[Musique]
bonjour j'ai rendez vous avec pierre
coffin prévenait nous a parlé d'accord
mais je vous en prie je rappe et habitat
ouais ouais c'est vrai c'est un peu
comme ça mais ça ouais c'est là ok on y
va je te fais vraiment intéressante il
ya vraiment
or pierre faire c'est quoi c'est quoi ça
c'est emile ranson café
non
je vais présenter quelqu'un way que
génial s'appelle bébé bonjour et bbb en
fait ils dessinent plein de minions
d'accord donc si tu as des questions
déposées
c'est le spécialiste déjà j'ai envie de
savoir comment par quoi on commence pour
faire un mignon on commence par les yeux
par le corps par les bras ou par la
bouche ça c'est intéressant oui parfois
on commence je commence par les yeux
qu'il en est des les yeux oulaï parce
qu'il ya des monos mono mignon et des
débuts mignon tout ça par exemple pour
être content mais pourrait aussi être
triste pour faire mignon qui ressemble à
galles voilà alors j'ai une question
fondamentale à existentielle pourquoi
ils sont jaunes ou la droite pour ça il
faut appeler le centre jeunesse à vous y
ajouteront eric guillon lui eric ça lui
allait tous mourir tu présentes galles
il a deux trois questions à se poser
j'ai demandé à cb pourquoi les minions
était jaune et tout de suite il a dit il
faut appeler le 110 g résurgence donc
voilà je voudrais avoir là en fait parce
que la salopette et bleu moi je trouve
que ça collait bien bleu jaune
donc voilà ok et le nez pourquoi pas
donné moi ils n'osent en fait ils mignon
ce sont des gélules et les gélules qui
ça n'a pas de merci rick nash a bien
tout va bien je te présente et bobette
donc je rejette donc la bête et
animatrice qu'une fois que gb ou
d'autres j'en fais ton
ont conçu des personnages sont modélisés
par voir des gens puis on met des
squelettes dedans fait pour les
manipuler c'est des gens comme babel qui
les manipulent les manipulatrices tient
pas la seule star tu n'as tu ris tu peux
le faire sauver le sourire
et donc si on veut tous faire bouger si
on veut faire une marche par exemple
tout ça ça nécessite deux à chaque
moment précis dans le temps on ne
déplace un membre devra le clé etc et
pourrait lancer fait ça c'est une
séquence du film la caméra ou de la
diarrhée est en fait à l'état une seule
histoire dans moi moche et méchant de en
fait les millions disparaît ce sont
kidnappés au fur et à mesure mais là
c'est le sait la dernière séquence où
ils sont quasiment tous attrapé le bien
ça
moi je vais prendre un petit café tu
veux boire quelque chose comme si pour
kitano la catho espoirs écouter les bars
et l ami spaghetto la clé d'accord mais
avec ou sans sucre quotas
[Musique]